right no that's some real [__] it's
crazy because um I do feel like you know
if there's anybody who can kind of lead
a real change in Renaissance into how
this is thought of um I think it's you
man cuz I've SE I've seen it I saw
Curtis King post his [__] from even
right what is even so even is a uh an
all- incompetent platform eventually is
going to grow to artist Hub where are
part of it or you yeah I have Equity
okay so you have equity and even I've
been seeing people post their the very
first launch [__] Spotify Recaps this
what I did me
hilarious yeah man even as an all-
incompetent platform for artists like we
just give artists the ability to
monetize and sell their music if they
don't have their own situation some some
artists don't have a Shopify setup or or
just want want to have a website and all
that [__] and even makes it easy for the
fans to come support and buy your music
directly from you what's the play so my
whole thing with the with the third
party [__] right is we're so conditioned
to play music on certain apps so if I
buy an album on
even it's it's set up just like Spotify
it's an inapp streaming so it's so I'll
download the even app on my phone right
so if
I based it's web based so it's not so
that's what y got to figure out
eventually it'll get that cuz that's
that for as a fan for Fan Experience
purposes right that's what you want you
want to be able to be like oh cool I got
my even library of all the [__] I've
supported yeah definitely and I I
believe he built a web base based off
like data that people were still kind of
going online for specific and it's like
even was really built from the dirt a
year ago like I just did the very first
launch last year when I did 100,000 on
that album that was the first anybody's
heard of it in existence and I campaign
the whole proud to pay offer like this
[__] was built from the dirt and in one
year we've gotten Omar and dizy and a
bunch of major labels are on boarding
now like the majors are going to even so
they can run their upcoming atist I
wonder like uh cuz yeah I wish I feel
like if I was an upand cominging artist
I would want to have that option like is
that when we get worked into my deal
where like yo if I want to be able to
you guys might get a cut of this but
right I want to be able to sell my [__]
you're right for maybe the first I mean
a lot of artists see when you going into
the major system it's so different cuz
it's very hard to sell music that you
don't own it
is straight up very hard yeah you got to
ask permission
right yo um can you give me some insight
on like uh how
influential nipy has been cuz nipy was
kind of the first guy to do the pr the
p pioner in so many ways nip is the
reason I decided to start doing proud to
pay and I feel like I revolutionized it
another tier by doing offer based so I
started with proud to pay I was riding
my bike and I was like thinking about
nip $100 album and I was like man how
can I do this but in a way that's
conducive to my people cuz I didn't know
too many [__] who would pay 100 for an
album so I was like I'm just going to
let [__] pay whatever because if I
make $1 over zero then I won right so I
started doing pay what you want and I
and I end up doing a live show that was
pay what you want and I made less than I
projected but I noticed that people
don't want to pay a certain amount at
the door cuz there's hell people around
so typically some [__] would give me a
rack a 100 but you don't want to do that
at the door with people behind you so I
I end up creating offer based when I
start doing my backyard I was like let's
start doing offer based
because I can't I can't set a ticket
price on this experience like you came
to the backyard we' had shows with s
there and different people come out so
it's like how can man I can't say this a
$20 ticket a $5 ticket $30 none of that
makes sense to me so I'm like you tell
me what what you think this experience
is worth and all I could do is say yes
or no for this one you feel me and um
was it hard to figure out the back end
of the offer based thing because I've
never seen like any website offer
something where you no it was new with
the technology was completely new like I
got what my partner Brea he created a a
ticketing site called West TBA that just
sold regular tickets and when I came I
was like man I got this idea I need to
build a tech behind it so I could do my
shows a certain way and we just started
this last year like I said I did half a
million on what's TVA offer Bas shows
last year I think that's the future if
you're smart man it's the present ain't
going for exactly you especially when
you um when you have a real live show
and a real live experience and something
like me where you get to holler at me
and talk to me and I'm around like when
you know what it eventually it gets to
the point where people stop offering you
L like people are just like I know what
I'm getting and I know what this [__] is
worth and what it means to me yeah like
if um certain artists who are like a
certain level end up taking that and
running with it it's going clean up
clean up I even think of like a guy like
you know I always you you always hear a
couple of names Drake Kendrick like if
they ever decided to go independent it
would break the music industry clean up
like if Drake decided to be like clean
up [__] the labels are pissing their
pants he would break the music industry
forever yeah I mean right now there's a
lot of slow work towards that but that's
they know that which is why they're okay
running him h a quarter billion and pl
because they know they know like he's
he's he's responsible for saving the
industry at a at a specific time so they
know yeah like and and I think it guys
like the weekend like the weekend's team
his infrastructure that isn't the label
just his team is so on point I'm like
mhm yo at what point can the label do
anything but write you a [__] check
that and that's eventually it gets to
that point and I honestly and truly feel
like I'm getting to that point now like
after this run I'm about to have in
2024 at this point there's not much they
could do but even now the offers I get
is like y'all got to you can only run a
Check and which you should want to when
you see a [__] already got a business
completely established and built all you
want to do is get a cut cuz you don't
have to do nothing it's like I came you
and say oh you got a pizza spot let me
just give you some bread and give me a
percent every month that's a win
definitely don't have a pizza spot uh
officially publicly but maybe soon it
it'll be announced on my Instagram that
was like a random you know I do have a
nightclub that's very successful in
scottd yeah I seen that shout out to uh
my business partners perfect example hey
man we tried to get people to invest it
was it's just three of us and uh
everybody who said no within the first
month were like hey can we get in and
I'm like [__]
no right cardi B and Meek Mill and
everybody's like yo man look if you guys
still need a second phase of money I'm
like no we're good now like everybody
don't see it everybody don't see it and
and that is the main thing I think that
you're a testament of bro is because
these conversations I'm telling you
about that I've had with people right
they don't see it and they don't get it
and they're a they're oblivious to like
all you got to do is see it that's all
and people are you know if you believe
in what you're doing and you're sure of
it and you got good people around you
who aren't yes men [__] if somebody who
don't like [__] [__] with what what some
anr thinks [__] with some label
executive thinks like make them see your
vision it be tough it be tough and
that's easier said than done right
that's easier said than done man it's
tough to to to stay down cuz you get
offered these sums and you want to go
but it man you really got to stick to
like and you got to have a workout other
thing is Major label might be for you if
you're lazy yeah I think the ma your
work ethic is insane I think the majors
are necessary because there there are
some artists that are just insanely
talented but they don't have the um the
care or desire to do all the other [__]
to make sure the world I think the
labels are even for a [__] like me like
if we find the right label with the
right deal I'm gone cuz I'm already gone
it's like I'm not on a major and I'm on
every major platform and [__] know
it's got to be the right deal though
that's it